nos dicen un teléfono se vende por 600
pesos y pierde el 25% de su valor cada
año escribe la función para obtener el
valor del teléfono
dt el valor es una función del tiempo de
años después de su venta pagos el vídeo
y piénsalo antes de trabajar juntos muy
bien ahora vamos a pensarlo juntos para
ello podemos crear una tabla en la
columna izquierda tenemos ate y en la
derecha al valor del teléfono como una
función del tiempo nos dicen que el
teléfono se vende por 600 pesos por lo
tanto entre igual a cero cuánto es ve de
cero bueno desde cero es igual a
seiscientos pesos esto es por lo que se
vende entre igual a cero
ahora qué pasará entre igual a uno nos
dicen que el teléfono pierde el 25% de
su valor cada año otra forma de escribir
que pierde el 25% de su valor cada año
es que retiene el 100 por ciento menos
25 por ciento es 75% el 75 por ciento de
su valor cada año
entonces cuál es su valor después de un
año bueno tiene un valor de 600 pesos
por el 75% que hay del segundo año bueno
va a tener el valor del primer año por
75% de nuevo es decir valdrá 600 pesos
por 75% por 75 por ciento de nuevo o
podemos escribirlo como 600 pesos por
75% elevado al cuadrado y ya podemos ver
el patrón en general si pasan tres años
entonces el valor del teléfono en pesos
será 600 x y escribiremos 75 % como
decimal por 0.75 en lugar del 75%
elevado a la potencia t
por lo tanto vdd es igual a 600 por 0.75
elevado a la potencia t y lo hemos
logrado hagamos otro ejemplo aquí nos
dicen un biólogo tiene una muestra de
seis mil células el biólogo introduce un
virus que mata un tercio de las células
cada semana escribe una función para
obtener el número de células restantes
en la muestra ctt el número de células
restantes son una función del tiempo
tres semanas después de que se insertó
el virus una vez más pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo
muy bien de nuevo hagamos otra tabla
tenemos al tiempo t en semanas y al
número de células restantes sé que es
una función del tiempo entre igual a 0
cuando han pasado 0 semanas tenemos a
6000 células lo cual es bastante claro
después de una semana cuántas células
nos quedan es decir cuánto es cd1 bueno
nos dicen que el virus mata un tercio de
las células restantes cada semana que es
otra forma de decir que todos tercios de
las células van a sobrevivir para la
siguiente semana por lo tanto después de
la primera semana tendremos seis mil por
dos tercios ahora en la segunda semana
transcurrida otra semana tenemos dos
tercios del número de células restantes
que teníamos la primera semana es decir
seis mil
por dos tercios por dos tercios que es
lo mismo que seis mil por dos tercios
esto elevado al cuadrado así que una vez
más podemos ver el patrón entre igual a
cero tenemos seis mil y después cada
semana que pasa multiplicaremos seis mil
por dos tercios multiplicado por sí
mismo cuántas semanas hayan transcurrido
entonces las células como funciones de t
en semanas será nuestra cantidad inicial
y luego por dos tercios multiplicado por
sí mismo cuántas semanas hayan
transcurrido es decir de veces por dos
tercios elevado a la potencia t y hemos
acabado